here's a question some of us ask every
year what does dear old dad want for
father's day
well maybe some hector i don't know
maybe some golf lessons that won't break
the bank and they can watch the us open
at the same time yeah there's an idea
good morning hector how's it going at
topgolf
good morning guys we are celebrating
father's day early here with mr pretzel
here happy early father's day to you mr
pretzel
we're also here with mary who's going to
talk to us about everything they have
planned for father's day good morning to
you good morning
so what do you guys have planned we're
actually opening an hour early so we're
being at 9am to welcome fathers and
families in early to celebrate
we also have a special if you can't make
it out that you can purchase a 75
gift card for dad for every 75 dollars
you get a 20
game play bonus card it's obviously a
pretty cool venue we have those
large screens for you know people to
watch the games and also this weekend
the us open yeah absolutely so
we play every game you can imagine on
these screens and during those times
we'll turn the sound down so you can
really get into the environment almost
like you're there
and that sound is pretty loud yes yeah
it's definitely an immersive experience
and you know it's also pretty immersive
and pretty loud that view out there
check out how nice it looks this morning
as the sun rises and we uh
we've been taking some lessons all
morning long and
just earlier just about half an hour ago
i did not hit the ball
but i'm not embarrassed because i was
actually hitting the ball earlier right
this is lindsay yes hi everybody um yeah
you were hitting the ball very well
earlier
and now you've graduated to hitting off
the ground
i did shall i yes so
here we go okay it's all good about the
lessons you guys have
yeah so we have private lesson packages
group lessons
so look at that see just after a couple
hours
that's our wildlife here at topgolf but
yes yes
there was a hummingbird here once too
but yeah yeah so
uh you know we have all different kinds
of lessons though so group lessons
individual lessons we have junior
academy still going on for two more
weeks so
there's a lot of options to get
instruction here at topgolf
so i'm not the worst student emma no no
you've done well
but you got to look at the ball there we
go there perfect
all right awesome great job thank you
very much so this is just
one way to celebrate father's day let me
put this over here off to the side
so this is one day to celebrate father's
day speaking of fathers i wish my dad
was here this morning
but i am hopping on a plane after work
around noon
flying back home arriving with a cake to
celebrate father's day with my dad mr
enrique feliz dia de los padres
i'll be home there in a few hours so
we'll be there to celebrate
oh enrique happy father's day to your
dad hector you're so sweet
what a sweet son yeah good stuff hector
and you can give him some golf lessons
that you've learned this morning yeah
you can give him all your i don't think
anyone wants to take off lessons from me
i do hector you know those birds though
yeah he's like no
those birds are flying away though every
time you uh take us yeah no people out
there but we have some pigeons out there
flying
luckily i didn't hit that on kitchen and
that one hummingbird that one time
yeah one time thanks thank you